[Music]
hey so can I get something no trust me
you're gonna need a drink to get through
this challenge now a ground zero
wait don't make it too obvious but there
are six guys checking out right now and
one of them it's a total [ __ ] boy now
you don't know what a [ __ ] boy is a [ __ ]
boy is the man who feels entitled to a
woman's time without putting any
emotional investment into earning it and
yes one of these six gentlemen is a
secret [ __ ] boy you just let to find out
which one it is
Oh first up Jake to just buy you a shot
right over there shot more like skull
wad I mean my body is like a temple call
me the Taj Mahal of people the Jake
Mahal next up we got hunter in the suit
back at that table to literally buy this
whole bar right now
what my father is gonna hear about this
you wouldn't say your [ __ ] prayers
you're coming to town
oh we got another drink from Tristan
back at the pool table
that's Tristan
Kristen okay Tristan's not mute he's
just really pretty oh looks like we got
a nice rose a from Craig over here just
down the bar hi there I just wanted to
say that I think you have a very polite
face and you have hair that would go
right on a wing if you ever wanted to
donate it Craig does not have any
friends oh I think hey Alan also back
the full table wanted to get you this
why do girls always date [ __ ] and
then were nice guys like me I mean
that's a $12 drink you're drinking
that's a pretty nice guy move if I have
to say so myself I mean what would you
consider a nice guy
Alan okay well last but not least we got
Milo over there by the jukebox
do you like indeed progressive ghost
rock what's your favorite fire
I like whether we their first album is
much better than the first another I
knew none of those bands but anyway take
one last look around you one of these
six guys it's totally a secret [ __ ] boy
which one is it leave your opinion down
in the comments below and no it is
definitely not me